"The death toll continues to rise
at a fatal gas line explosion in Mexico."
"Authorities say that the pipeline
had been ruptured by
suspected oil thieves."
People were lighting cigarettes,
they were dancing,
they were throwing gasoline
on top of each other.
Completely intoxicated by the fumes.
"They took their fill
as soldiers sent to guard
the pipeline looked on
seemingly powerless.
Then this happened."
And essentially in a matter of seconds,
the whole thing ignited.
People were running from the blast
like human torches.
It was complete chaos.
"The most important thing now
is to look after the injured,
to save lives.
That is the most important thing.
The fight against the
illegal theft of fuel
will be strengthened."
The state loses in the region of
three billion U.S. dollars a year
and the 95 percent of what is known as
tomas clandestinas,
which are illegal extractions,
are done by big cartels.
My name is Matthew Bremner
I'm a Scottish writer.
I wrote the story about Mexico's
biggest pipeline explosion.
Within the first sort of 24 hours,
people said there were 20 people dead
and 71 people injured.
Obviously those numbers rocketed up
but the final death
toll, as it were, is 134.
Now in the field where
the irrigation trench was
where the pipeline runs,
framed by an old tree which
was scorched in the blast
there is now a shrine.
Almost every day, relatives
of the victims go there.
They sit on little plastic
benches or wooden crates.
They stare at the crosses, often crying.
Sometimes in some sort of trance.
And they spend hours there.
It's the same always in society,
the people who are at
the bottom of the tree,
the people that were there
looking to take advantage
of an opportunity.
They're the people that always suffer.
The scale of oil theft
in Mexico is enormous.
The state loses 3 billion
US dollars a year.
Huachicolero, which is
the illegal siphoning
and tapping of fuel
which has been happening in Mexico
now for about 25 years, perhaps longer.
What was a very informal industry
has now become something
which is far more organized.
A lot of the big Mexican cartels
are now branching into
this sale of oil theft.
Half of their business is now focused
on illegal fuel tapping.
It's a lot less risky, essentially,
to get involved in illegal fuel trade
because you don't need to
transport drugs across borders.
You don't need to pay off
different types of police
in different countries.
The corruption inside
the big petrol giant,
in this case Petróleos
Mexicanos, Pemex, is rampant.
And so it's quite easy to
pay off workers inside,
to find out when the oil is flowing
through certain pipelines
and to rob it
and then sell it domestically
on the black market.
Pemex is one of the biggest
oil companies in the world.
For a long time it was
considered a cash cow
for the Mexican economy.
It kept Mexico afloat in many ways
and people always refer to it
as the most important
institution that the country had.
The government recently released figures
that around 80 percent
of the tomas clandestinas
and the fuel robberies
that take place in Mexico
are organized in some
way by insiders in Pemex.
What would normally happen
is that they would have
a link inside Pemex
who would tell them through
which pipeline a certain,
it could be gasoline, it could be gas,
it could be anything,
is running and what
time and what the pressure is.
They would then go down
to the specific pipeline
normally at nighttime.
Normally the pipes are about
between one or two
meters below the ground.
They would dig to get to the pipeline.
Then would perforate it
with a high-powered drill.
Then a professional solderer would come in
and he would solder a tap to the pipe.
They know exactly what they're doing
when they do it
and the risks that it entails.
So they're professionals.
One of the huachicoleros in Hidalgo area
told me that in one night
the organization that he works for
can make up to 90 thousand pesos.
If you take into account
that an average wage,
at least in that area from
what people were telling me,
is about 15 hundred pesos a week.
Then, you know, we're
talking serious money here.
Around midday there was
a rumor that was spread
that a pipeline had been perforated
and that people were
illegally siphoning gasoline
from one of the biggest
pipelines in Mexico.
Around two thirty in the afternoon
a patrol of 25 officers
from the military arrived.
So this was quite an unusual occurrence
simply because normally fuel robberies
would take place at night.
Men, women, and children were turning up
in vans, in cars, on foot,
and on bicycles and motorbikes
and coming to the area in huge numbers.
Within the next two-to-three hours
what may have been 80 people
soon was six times that.
It felt like they were almost celebrating
in some sort of way.
It felt like a water
party, I heard people say.
Generally, they were
just local townspeople
who were taking advantage of
the situation to get free fuel.
One thing that's very important here
is the fuel that was running
through this particular
pipeline was very high octane.
Which meant that it released
lots of very, very, flammable gasses.
Because the day itself was relatively hot,
these gasses were sort of
floating above the crowd.
It hadn't yet got to the stage
where it was low enough to be ignited.
So around six o'clock when
it began to get darker
and the temperature dropped,
those gasses also dropped.
And so they sort of began
to smother the crowd.
Now the interesting thing is that the fire
created inside a cigarette butt
is not hot enough to ignite petrol
but what is hot enough
is static electricity.
And what would have probably happened
is that a static shock would
have come from somewhere
where there were two hands
that were being shaken
or friction created between two people
rubbing up against each other.
And that would have created a static shock
which would have been hot enough
to ignite these gasses
which had now sunk down.
And essentially within
a matter of seconds,
the whole thing ignited.
And as the ignition of the fire settles down somewhat
then you see the people
running from the blast.
And this is perhaps the
most impactful moment
because the people that
are running from the blast
are in flames.
Some of them trip over.
Some of them run towards the road.
Some of them are rolling on the ground.
Some of them are crying for water.
The local paramedics came in first
from the surrounding villages
and when they got to the field,
they saw people sort of
writhing on the floor in agony.
They saw charred bodies that
were completely incinerated.
Sort of falling apart.
People that were in their
last moments of agony but
burned into that position.
What they saw was the most horrific thing
that you could possibly
see, I can imagine.
The Mexican government has
declared war on huachicolero.
Are they winning it?
I think it's far too early to say.
Will they win it?
Well I think if the drug
war is anything to go by
then probably not.